speaking of which Yusuf and Johnny from
propane fitness are here today I hope
you look colleague the camera it's
possible because I was smelling my
armpit that's really not the worst thing
you've ever done a podcast is it so yeah
we're talking about life hacks today
those of us who addicted to trying to
make our lives more efficient and
optimal we're going to try and come up
with some interesting resources that we
use that have made our lives a little
bit more efficient I think that we all
come from different kinds of backgrounds
with what we need and what we choose to
use but then there's a lot of stuff that
we've crossed over with as well so it'll
be a combination of workflow tools apps
a few mobile phone strategies that we
use for making you like more efficient
and then probably quite a bit of stuff
that not none of us realized that the
other ones did and then we're gonna just
mock each other paint especially let's
go where he says yeah let's go up there
so most especially excited to would like
this who would like to open up the first
resource right sculpey Yuka's go ghost
okay well I'm just gonna begin very
basic and just say Apple products yes
yeah this is Johnny's as well because
Apple contains a suite of syncing but
the problem is you roped in as soon as
you begin you get a MacBook you have to
then get an iPhone and you get an iPhone
you have to get a Mac but otherwise you
just you're in the sink nightmare
between a annoyed or a PC device and
then something I am uncomfortable with
you looking at camera okay I quite like
it I ate makes me uncomfortable
right sorry guys that's just how I feel
Johnny is uncomfortable so well because
it's it's been like you all speak you're
over there you buy on their bucket the
camera I think not and smile at me and
then look at the congestion to the
camera yeah imagine that you're Alan
Shearer doing the Saturday afternoon
football okay talking into camera but
you Jess
cheering to the lads the way the lots so
the port you see I've just made the lot
so just I think it's a it's a fires
around up it's a round table okay
continue so such a rocky start to
podcast or the smoothest art we've ever
done maybe maybe so yeah
Apple products the main things that I
use them for the main things I use the
capture tools for so I Carl reminders
and Siri so hold on Siri remind me in
ten minutes whatever and you have at
least in either a section of reminders
or a note or something that's just your
immediate capture that stuff that while
you're on the go you just capture things
that may need to be done later and then
certain point in the day later you go in
bulk and take one of those things and to
capture and allocate them to a specific
time in your calendar so that's David
Allen's getting things done right
exactly get it out of your head get it
down on paper as fast as possible yeah
exactly to get it out of your head don't
let your mind hold these ideas because
so often what happens is you've got
something you think oh I need to fix
that nail in the fence which was his
example and then for the rest of the day
even if you forget what the thing you
had to do is you've still got this
general stressed thought of I need to do
the thing there's something I've got a
same thing that's left here and then
you're having a terrible time so I agree
yeah I think Apple products fantastic
like being over the sink just stuff like
your notes make me know when your phone
and then it appearing on your laptop I
think 10 years ago 15 years ago
the phones were the thing but that
syncing also wasn't a thing and then
when we do when you first get it's just
such a game-changing I don't understand
how people don't live have an iMessage
what's up web uh-huh yeah I mean like I
I was to joining the laptop it's
probably one of the biggest massively
shifts in instant shift in quality your
life how much do you text on your phone
how do only other like if I'm on my
laptop though because you're on your
laptop a lot yeah well you will yeah I'm
not gonna behind always something so
unlike my big Arab thumbs to huge eyes
does it do that so I'll just
like not dexterous enough yeah I just
don't bother with texting warfare I'm
not like excessive you need the
accessibility mode that my dad's on the
verge of needing big numbers I love it
when I see people this is like the terms
of phonemic calculator it's got its got
the keypad entry system from a Nokia
3310 with something like worth a
thousand yeah yeah right Johnny Europe
what's next well it's Apple was
technically money Apple is it's to
really cover all the things it does for
you you'd almost have to think about
this for an entire day because there's
so much stuff like even even things like
do not disturb mode for example note
syncing the availability of like so many
different apps can be on your phone and
on your laptop Evernote meditation apps
like I could run we can run propane I
know you can't because you've
deliberately remove things but if I had
to I could run the entire business from
my phone but I do I wouldn't live
business from my phone pretty much the
necessity for me to go on my laptop is
very very right really rare so what why
do you have a laptop but small
convenient that can work quicker typing
as soon as you give me quicker I don't
like the angle that my necks out when I
look at my phone like yeah you hunched
over irrelevant of whether you sat up at
a desk it's not good and I found that
what's this on the back of my neck what
are these muscles video traps is that
tractors run up to the backup is here
okay so I've found that my traps getting
looser at the top but my SCD and yeah SC
n which is what runs on the front of
your neck is getting tighter and I'm
absolutely adamant that a lot of that is
due to spending time with my head tilted
forward looking at my cell phone neck
yeah yeah for sure were easily naturally
with the laptop you are levels brought
up a little bit
I think there's problems like more
probably more so if you use a mouse but
people still sit and slug should sit but
you have their shoulders pillow
well posture when you posture 101 drop
in Fitness comically it's really good
crime it's not common for
slash posture great help I'm surprised
it didn't just quote a bit ly link right
come on after farmers use so I'm told
Gugu doji ELLs are all safe though is
that right yeah I he's taught me a few
good what's first of the other I'm gonna
say that the theme or the concert which
encompasses loads of things but the
concept of having a series of things
that you do in order every morning
before you do anything well in a morning
routine yeah but like it doesn't have to
be like a it might just be one thing
okay like it's it's I think for me
having rather than just saying I've
every team like things that I do it's
specifically like because I in the
morning I'm so open to I'll pick up my
like half asleep you making coffee pick
up your phone check email before you
know you've been sucked into this
situation at work or whatever if I just
make things as baby simple as possible
for myself okay so give I got give me a
minority so okay wake up downstairs
coffee general Fong's still upstairs
phones actually with me right so I'm
trying to to put less like physical Aria
isn't just I'm just not gonna look at it
okay Journal do the work meditate
downstairs make my girlfriend a cup of
tea make me potentially another coffee
depending on how far they're back
upstairs roll my yoga mat out in the
bedroom well back is getting ready
mobility do wrong would shower
downstairs
what's wrong what Johnny that's mine
this way it comes to so many things it's
fine
prioritize who they start with okay
so your your concept that you think that
everyone should be doing is having your
morning routine like a like it's like a
launch sequence for the day okay I think
how do you briefly in 60 seconds how do
you design one if you don't have if you
don't have to be mobile if you don't
have to run your own business so you
don't have to do but if how do you just
get up and get your day going quickly I
think trying to not find a point where
you get stuck in inertia is a big one
and the song is probably the worst for
that and the TV is probably up there as
well I think things that make you feel
organized and productive like I I feel
so it's it's all a half of it may even
be perceiver but if I've done those
things by the time I'm like stuck
working my mind is not thinking like I
said I was gonna blow a lot this morning
like I said I was going to meditate or
something's bothering me because I've
kind of dealt with that first so try and
get out in my own way mentally yeah
before doing things that require me to
sit and focus and be disciplined I think
that you can quite easily work out what
it is that you need to do in the morning
it's less about the things you need to
do and more about the things that you
shouldn't be doing as far as I'm
concerned there's certain things that
you can do on the morning that will make
you feel better
mmm but there's a lot of things that you
can do in the morning which will make
you feel a lot worse yeah like if you
there's so many so many of my friends
that I know that will get up on a
morning and they'll spend 45 minutes
cycling around all of the apps and their
phone clearing off all of the
notifications from the day before
like purely from a time efficiency
perspective as soon as you're traveling
to wherever you need to go you can do
that then yeah presuming that you're not
driving and therefore you're doing two
things at once as opposed to one thing
at once such a good point is I think if
you compare the worst case scenario
morning where you wake up and suddenly
your agenda that you were planning to do
in the day it gets absolutely sidelined
by all of the weather the urgent the
urgent but not important stuff yes no
comes up and you end up yeah cycling
through the apps or just complete and
then two hours later you're like well I
have plans for the day but I've got
nothing done that I needed to and I'm
pretty certain that we could do a full
episode on morning routine journaling
it's a big part of what I think all
three of us rely upon to get our days
moving correct
and I know that it's a case don't happy
for me if I have a good morning they're
likely at me having a good day's by a
factor of 10 more likely so if you want
us to do one on morning routine drops a
message or give me a tweet or something
and we'll put that together I think
there's a little bit of a finishing
point for that the phone thing it just
comes back to it we will be doing a
number of episodes on how to might use
your phone but the main the best thing
I've done is that I don't sleep with my
phone next to me anymore
my phone is on the opposite side of the
room next to the window so for me to go
and turn my phone alarm off I have to
get up and out of bed go turn it off at
the window then pull the blind in the
window till that light into my room and
then even if I get back to bed I can't
go to sleep again like as long as you're
happy with the way you feel like a
[ __ ] for going back to bed I don't
mind it I think I can go back to bed for
like five minutes boom I didn't I mean
bright daylight now so you can always
just face off can you justify it that
way no no I
I need this extra 15 minutes absolutely
that nice that voice that voice in your
head goes and then we could soon as
you're asleep you don't have control
over how long you're back back in bed
mm-hmm it's just such about it's a bad
bad way to start the day like citing it
with TV or started with your phone
it feels like what's that thing um Brian
Johnson sites where he says that someone
smoking a spliff drops the right cue by
15 points but someone on the phone drops
it by 25 so like in terms of the IQ
effect that being on your phone has
dudeney much stimulus you brain output
suffers larger than if he'd smoked a
joint that's put the phone down pick the
joint up is crazy
there's a lot of things like that way so
when they say driving while texting is
equivalent to driving under like six
units of alcohol yeah sleeping with your
phone in the room that you're in is
equivalent to like psychologically or to
the to the the impact that it has on
your quality of sleep is equivalent to
sleeping with your front door open
we've spoken about that yeah I see the
point but if does anyone else feel up do
you feel like when your phone's the room
you we're probably not as attached to it
no on it's an honest in the room I don't
but I definitely notice a difference
when I'm sat down and I can't see my
phone like if I can see even if it's I
always have it face down phone is always
face down now you want to get into a
meeting phone always goes facedown but
when I conceived even up the peripherals
in my eyes from start watching TV or and
start reading a book if the phone is
face down there I can see the black in
it it draws my mind towards thinking
that's another thing so in social
situations they said I can't remember
the number but it's if a phone is even
visible on the table even if it's not in
use it still diminishes the scent that
perceived sense of connection into
interaction by telephone I think that
you can get away with the phone what
maybe yes that's probably okay I'm gonna
do my first phone which I think we'll
all agree with which is rawat actually
Scobie you might not agree with this but
I think you said back up so robot is a
daily range of motion programming
website every single day they release a
roundabout 20-minute routine of the
mobility to do it's based on yin yoga
which is a slow slow long-held stretches
essentially it's mindful stretching the
reason it's so good I think is that it's
so prescriptive and it's something that
everybody almost universally and whether
you're an athlete or not whether you do
a lot of physical exercise or not almost
everyone would benefit from having an
improved range of motion from doing some
stretching day today there's so many
people here that said look you know I'd
love to do some stretching but I just
either can't find time or don't want to
do and the fact is that Ron Wood makes
it so easy for you to do it you put it
on either on your laptop or on your
phone there's a good mobile version of
the site and put either headphones in or
play through the speakers and a guy
talks you through the movements that
you're going to do and some good-looking
guys and girls on-screen demonstrate
them and they stay in the poses with you
for the entire time and then sometimes
it's controlled breathing that you have
to do along with it the it's it's just
fantastic it's such a good result you
have access to every workout that
they've ever put out before and you can
refine those down by what's tight so you
got
by back you got a bad neck we've got
about you've got tight hips you got
tight whatever you can put in the things
that they bothering you and it will do a
meta search there everything else and
then come up with a routine that it
thinks it's good for your selection of
routines and um yeah I think when I
started doing Crossfit which is
functionally and more demanding sport in
terms of my range of motion I my
mobility it's still not good enough but
was terrible from years of not looking
after it and now if you can imagine the
stretch that you do that used to be able
doing school where you put your hand one
hand goes up and behind your neck and
the other hand goes up your back and I
was never able to get my hands to touch
behind my back
where is now quite easily from cold I
can fall into it if you're just
listening you'll have to imagine how
lovely that looked but you got really I
can't get any doing Archer arms I'm
suing this morning straight in my so if
you were miles away right no was it the
start you know what I still can't do is
Eagle arms yeah yeah I think that's
because the dimensions if he's teased so
long titanically must get off your
[ __ ] huge no it's my it's mint
irritation on one sides worse is oh yeah
my right I think for me wrong wad is the
same benefit as having is outsourcing my
training in nutrition to a coach in the
sense that like I think mobility because
there are so many different ways
resources methodologies and like schools
of thought and how you should manage it
it's so easy to get caught up so much in
it that you just don't do anything or
you do something and overthink it and
worry it's not the best way to do it so
for me it's having someone else has put
at least some level of thought into it
there's some kind of I can feel some
kind of progression so the poses get are
getting gradually easier than we were
discussing and crucially for me I think
it's not it's not intrusively
painful or really challenging it's quite
relaxing it can be challenging it's the
exact right level of charity exactly I
said you don't come away from thinking
like that daeho or like dread doing it
I got quite like having this part my
morning there's a couple today the first
post was if you can imagine the side
splits basically it was
straight into a standing straddle which
is your feet as wide apart as you can
standing up straight and then lowering
down on your hands and to go into that
from cold mmm it's not it's not horribly
challenging but it's pretty tough and
you have to kind of really focus on your
breath and the benefits that I think me
and to you Johnny of syndrome and I
think scum your I think your benefits
from yogurt like there's a microbes good
it's gone it's just this girl isn't it
crumbly old school this going this go on
the lemon yeah I think I think that the
benefits that all of us have seen from
the ogre mobility over the years justify
doing this you can get a seven day free
trial at the links to everything by the
way links to everything will be in the
description below where we can find
discount codes we'll put them in if not
then grit your teeth and and buy all on
one so cheap before you get but it's
seven dollars a month for $14 it more
you know a type of ten having quit but
ten power ten pounds a month for you to
have basically someone delivering you a
fantastic yoga workout using you and I
would pay what 10 quid a yoga session
per week yeah so we're paying forty
pounds a month for four hours of yoga
and now we pay 10 pounds month for daily
it's not the same it's not exactly the
same and you can get free yoga online
yes but I think the how easy it is how
accessible it is the level of
programming involved and it looks good
as well nice yeah yeah nicest thing to
use it's a good experience and that's
part and parcel a bit the platform's
simple so yeah you should you should
definitely check out it's got 7 day free
trial for sure and then every so often
they might even bump up CrossFit open is
starting soon I'm gonna guess that
they'll probably do maybe a 14 day
around about them so if you wait until
the back end of February that they'll
probably be a good show do you want to
give the anti wrong would I originally
didn't like Ron would because of the
lack of focus on the breath and the lack
of the flow between poses since then
Ron what seems to have improved that and
they've taken more influence from yoga
but the biggest thing is as Johnny said
is there's value in just having a
prescriptive
routine to do regardless of what it is
you're just gonna turn up and do it and
it's the other value in doing the yoga
class rather than trying to yoga on your
own where you're much more likely to
give in quicker or just be paralyzed by
choice and justicar I'm not gonna bother
exactly he said like people are oh I
want to go into some stretching but I
just earn all that started you know what
to do it's like if you just like will
watch this video and do what the man
let's do it yeah exactly I think there's
an underlying assumption here or an
underlying problem and you guys propane
Rob an article just stick to the program
and I think the point is that I don't
remember writing that but I'm more than
happy to take credit I did write it past
Johnny edit I must say I mean I must
have done and yeah it was a it was
really good basically what it says is
that if you've got something which is a
system which works or something which is
a system which is prescriptive and laid
out stick to it long term because people
are too too prepared to flip between
different approaches to anything that
they're trying to achieve and within the
space of two weeks so they didn't see
progress mm-hm well there's entry
barriers to everything that you're doing
well we get it with clients a lot and
they complain about the results they
didn't get from the program they didn't
follow we go that's just like well if
you start to something enough to see the
result you'd be able to make the
decision yourself as to whether it's
working for the other the place to be in
is to be able to say that didn't work or
that did work and if you can say knife
chopping and changing doesn't give you
the privilege to say either so I
actually gave up Ron want Chris I
remember this day that's a message ever
I was like Chris there was some terrible
news and I stopped doing wrong one and
it was just I think probably just I
would have not really seen much benefit
from it after six months changed did
something a little bit different and
then decided to come back to Ron Wood
and funnily enough another two or three
months and sort of all these
improvements have come through once
mm-hmm and that just shows that like it
took me literally new to me a year of
doing it but suddenly a lot a lot of the
poses feel much easier mm-hmm I start to
see improvements fairly quickly I'd say
although they manifested themselves in
my performance a lot later but Ron what
you should dry if Ron Mott isn't for you
or if for some reason
can't access it then find yourself a
similarly prescriptive stretch and
routine that you did consistently but
ROM odd as far as we're concerned has
been the most effect upon them by I
can't do because I know your suggestion
is like find a yoga routine online and
follow that I just can't do that I don't
find a good deed but I think the best
thing go to a class because it's just
the most foolproof iya way but a lot
less convenient you can't do that
especially because I like doing rock my
first thing in the morning upon waking
it's a lot less appropriate I think
they're trying to do different things I
don't know I think Ron woods is 20 to 20
minute maintenance for a team yeah Ron
water seems more performance
specifically and I think if you're doing
it for performance benefits and you are
a lifter weightlifter crossfitter a
power lifter a bodybuilder then
definitely Ron what is the one right
what's next for you let's go
so I've been I've just have a look
through my list and everything falls
into capture habits or media consumption
okay so let's go media consumption I
want one I want one one from the top and
three from the bottom consonant and a
vowel media consumption so you know what
I'm gonna have to kind of capture first
because you can fit bands Mesa Carol
Carol I said so the way that you know
which media to even consume is through
your capture process so I use either
stuff that trusted people send you and I
know it's gonna be good I put it in
resume to abuse which open to accuse but
I'll put it into a play cue is either a
read cue or a play cue this is done
through Toby which is a Chrome browser
extension you then can split things into
libraries of things to watch things to
listen to things to read you can then if
you want to allocate them on the top of
the bottom as two different varies
varying grades of procrastination either
it's full bait like really
procrastination really progressed so
frustration cross in my worried yeah I
didn't understand you installed Toby on
my laptop a night
I'd still didn't understand what it was
until the other day toby is basically
it's kind of like a bookmark manager so
it's a combination between the bookmark
finding during a reading list that is
displayed nicely and visually on our new
tab page yep so every time you open
every time you command + T a new tab
open on Chrome you see the things that
you potentially should be doing or some
other things that you can do to stop
yourself from doing the things you
should be doing yeah exactly so the
purpose of that is that you've captured
and you've eliminated the decision of
what should I read watch like watch
whatever is you sit down you you've
taken that micro decision out of every
moment and you just have it there you
have a cue that's getting out of that
again it's a melon all over again
yeah it's only the brave the brain isn't
tremendously good at remembering things
it's good at decision making and doing
hmm so it doesn't want to have to store
the reminder of the memory of this is
why like what should I be doing
it's get it in front of you get out of
crack on totally and the other sorry how
do you so you talked about CAPTCHA yeah
how does it go from so Chris sends you
funny cat video mmm how does that end up
at Toby so copy the link add it into
Toby okay so that part you have got
anything just manually collect that
automatically correcting things and you
I have with with some things where if
I'm listening to actually this is kind
of the next stage so so see you have the
capture it also means that it minimizes
your but your procrastination because
you're not going to be just randomly
surfing the internet because you've got
a list of things that are vetted and you
want to be reading or listening or
watching so lectures audio books that
kind of things what I'm into as I so
Toby is for stuff on browsers mp3
audiobook player is something that isn't
a phone app that that sounds really
snide it is very snide isn't it that's
why it works it works very well
there's many mp3 audiobooks you can get
or YouTube has a huge number of
audiobooks for free and if you use
youtube to mp3 converter you can
download them into an mp3 put it on your
phone when you play it'll store your
spot and there's also a sleep timer
you can adjust the speed as well says
it's a fool it's neither audible for
when you've downloaded it yourself
exactly it's neither audible and I use
audible - so which is accident so is
there anything on it's not inaudible
that you can go on mp3 there you know if
they suppose unless there's a number of
things that you character or the world's
only got two hundred thousand titles I'm
aware that they're the main two hundred
thousand anyone who's releasing a book
now is releasing inaudible as well but
two thousand titles in the entirety of
our literate literacy history mystery is
not tremendously like your comprehensive
is that I would just Whittle the
limitation for lies that they aren't an
audiobook rather than they aren't an
audio combination movie combination
that's the most of the reason I called
herbal is for modern titles that wrote
harder to get through tonight recharge
YouTube will tend to have classics so if
you want to listen to like Aldous Huxley
or you know any kind of old novels or
anything like that there will be some
stone school British man reading it out
on there so you've got taught you've got
Toby for capture I hope you for capture
what's up what's up next Johnny what's
your next one oh yeah what why'd you get
Toby is it just Google like Toby Chrome
extension yeah I had a really good one a
second ago I thought oh it's a linker to
that which is is just something that I
decided to do what was the thing I was
going to say ah but OOP
so with CAPTCHA and the David Allen
thing there's there's definitely and
this is this applies to anyone I think
you have stuff that is just accumulating
in your life every day all the time
someone says something to you message
pops up email whatever stuff to do and I
think like as much as we'd all like to
always have something there to capture
it and write it down we don't always
have that so there's a there's two
things there's a PDF and there's a
podcast that David Allen's done which is
a guided Brenda guided mind sweep
there's a podcast of him literally just
talking and he goes through things he's
like okay professional life think about
things that were said to you yesterday
look at your calendar over the last week
and it sounds weird but if you sit with
a bit of paper or like a blank document
and just listen this stuff that comes
out of your head of like like something
that someone said to me ten days ago
that I would have completely
so either the sort of thing that you
just start watching TV suddenly goes
like ah I'm heavy yeah prevent that on I
think a lot of time when I'm meditating
I'll sit down to meditate and I'll have
an idea they'll come to me or a memory
of something that I need to do for later
in the day and it's that silencing of
the amount of stimulus that we've got
going on so suddenly it yeah I got mine
and you go hmm and then once I finish
meditating it's there it is still that
and I think spending a little bit of
time with a with a bit of silence or
actually rechecking through the last few
days of mini pots it's probably pretty
good idea if you don't get that stuff
out your head it does create this
background hum definitely keeping a few
accumulators just there's something that
I need to do my caramel what is yeah
it's just right it's just a chronic
version so doing doing that like a
couple of times a week I think just
really helps working people find that if
you search David Allen Google David
Island guided mine sweep okay is it as
literal as a PDF that I've just got
saved on my desktop and just look down a
list of things and you're like [ __ ] and
it makes you feel so basic because
you're like that's obviously just sat in
my subconscious ready to ready to pop up
at some point but they just need a
trigger okay next up I'm gonna do
optimize Hey so optimized on me is a
website by a guy called Brian Johnson
who is not the lead singer of ac/dc he
might be he might be pretty certain he's
not unless he's leading it outlandish
double life as a bald American guy
that's a life coach trip and also all
old American
raka from Newcastle so it's it's a
website where he summarizes books and
concept there's so much I think he's
taught 500 book summaries now yeah
there's a lot his intention is to do a
thousand that's his goal to do a
thousand he's done 500 a lot of them are
nonfiction self-help personal
development spirituality but it goes
full range of topics used on ones on
breath methods endurance running
bodybuilding a lot of stuff like all the
classics in terms of personal
development David Allen's books on there
we've been talking about how to win
friends and influence people by Dale
common master classes as well as nice
that's what that's what's really good
nothing Johnny that when you were on
optimize that's what you liked so yeah
if you can imagine that this guy is
doing around about every week to every
five days is releasing a book summary
and then around about every month to
every two months he will compile ten
around about ten key concepts within a
field and he'll then release a master
class so if you can imagine that he
skims that the top filtering of the best
of out of each book and then skims the
top filtering of each book into a
concept and that is what creates the
master class so if you're the sort of
person who maybe struggles to read or
stick themselves into a book for an
extended period of time
this switch was me is me still was me
specifically a year in a bit ago and
still is me now this is really really
useful because you just get the key
take-home points with some really really
good examples so go through ten ten key
lessons within a particular concept
usually from ten separate books maybe a
couple they don't cross over so that's a
breathing 101 nutrition 101 sleeping 101
depression 101 how to make a habits
anxiety everything and all of this
that's backed by whichever book he's
been in so you get the best of the best
displayed in maybe a 90 minute either
mp3 or a video and the amount of
resources that you get with it is really
impressive if there's a workbook that's
attached with each master class there's
a pollster that comes that's attached
with each book you can either read
a blog version of most of the book
summaries which is the transcript from
the audio version there's also a video
version there's a mobile partner arc
which safety position that you have if
you're doing it on desktop desktop
things really good it really is a it's a
pretty powerful and overwhelming
resource once you get into it I do feel
like his demeanor is probably a bit
testing at times and that might be one
of the mitigating factors in why you
stop doing it I'm not sure yeah I think
his so a lot of the books that he
covered not really of interest to me
like he studies recently he's done every
single one of the Harry Potter's alright
really interest that's not what I'm you
want to be the summary offer is it maybe
it is obviously this otherwise you've
done it I'm not sure but like I think
there's a lot of sort of very niche diet
books that he was covering yeah like
that was a lot of solution yeah and like
things about you know movie or DNA and
all this sort of thing like I I get why
he's doing that but it's just not
interesting to me and then the I found
that a lot of the master classes so this
this is gonna be my next one but except
there's a lot of a lot like a tidal wave
of information yes doesn't like like and
you watch a master class type [ __ ]
how like it's gonna take me a month to
just apply all that to disseminate 90
minutes and it's all it's like it there
almost needs to be a syllabus in the
curriculum to sit if you want to
actually Universal do stuff with it yeah
yeah that's like a three year course
isn't it realistically this is we come
back to watching things on multiple
times speed which is yeah we can go
through that so might well my point
about Brian Johnson which is also my
next thing which is the I so I signed up
for optimize as well I think we've all
gotten account at what we will have me
out absolutely his demeanor is a bit
difficult and the master classes is too
much of a wave of information and that's
which we need to say that for you to say
that this image information yeah
made it my business over the last five
years to inseminate large amounts of
information it worked
not by choice I just so for anyone is
literally in business I I am a medical
student and people describe studying
medicine like drinking from a firehose
so the goal is to try and just catch as
much as you can and it's very stressful
but yeah the problem is every book that
is summarized we have to remember that
somebody's life work somebody's life the
research project or whatever and he's
trying to buy ten of them into it now or
you know the last 45 minutes and they'll
be like eleven points that each have
four or five books disappear so what
happens is you don't get the time under
tension you don't get the time of
exposure when you're listening to
summaries to really fully assimilate the
information and integrate it into your
life and that was the it's great because
in here oh wow these are all fantastic
ideas but it's if you get stuck in that
it just quite masturbatory because
you're not really it's just a bunch of
like inspiring self-help stuff it turns
into it turns into cliche sayings and
and headline concepts rather than
understood octuple habits and changes
isn't it exactly arm and that that's
interested so what's up next so my well
so my workflow to solve that is I've
gone back to listening to full audio
books giving myself full time under
exposure I'm not doing two times speed
as much or three times you're gonna say
while you were even doing that in the
first book just simply the mindless
acquisition of efficiency and cramming
more information into one so I think
YouTube YouTube natively has a speed up
speed right yeah but I've got it I've
got a little hack for that as well which
moves it up to four times speed below
what can you learn the whole bottom
speak could you actually understand
you're dependent depends on the speaker
some people normal very normal normal
Hayden's could any could you understand
anyone at four times speed not only
non-technical information when you start
learning about like trying to do like
physiology
[Music]
so you being beaten by urination the
flatmates would always like they've come
in and just here like we take this
verbal diarrhea and so things down yeah
audiobooks I then take notes and
summaries as I go along just in the
middle Apple notes file on my phone or
whatever just some of the key points put
that into an Evernote file and then set
a reminder through Evernote which gives
you an option to certain notes to have a
date to remind you and send you an email
and a push notification to then be the
review and so then you can take the
actionable points that you've taken in
context and you've learned in a bit more
of a structured skeleton and then try
and action them individually and once
you've done that you clear the reminder
and you move on to the next thing and I
think Johnny is the best person I've
ever seen just implementing information
I just mindlessly index information I've
got hundreds of book summaries hundreds
of stuff that I've summarized never seen
anyone anyone's collection of work that
they've done themselves there's so much
yeah it's crazy fast and it's helpful it
sometimes you know with Q&A with my
clients for example I very often this I
can't think of many times where I've not
had an answer for a question their
client has asked yeah because it's such
a broad field yeah which is helpful but
tomorrow any notes topic 2300 notes on
Evernote
how many notebooks let's see you might
as well do Evernote straight after this
display this hello into Evernote because
if anyone doesn't know however that
works oh go ahead we complete it's a
it's an external brain it's a prosthetic
brain
yeah it's a USB Drive a bit for you your
thoughts is the exactly 58 notebooks
teeth are two three four five notes how
do you feel in a in a single word if you
can if Evernote went down forever it has
in the past so you have to take backups
okay so let's say irreversibly all of
your backups and all of them I was gonna
have to start again like how would you
feel that doesn't it's the same way to
let your house burning down Marcus would
you rather your house burned down or
your Evernote obviously I think when you
and I travel together we both have our
laptops with us hmm I don't know anyone
else who feels like I won't leave my
laptop in a car or carry my backpack
with my laptop in you're worse than me
and it's because there's all of your
Evernote in there as well luckily
Evernote is backed up when it's on the
cloud everything right take this take us
through do 120 seconds on whatever no is
going okay Evernote is a way to it's a
word processor but also a way to index
any of those documents into folders
subfolders tags there's a you can find
any of those notes in very quickly the
search function is very powerful so so
most people have been exposed to notes
on iPhone or whatever the equivalent is
on Android right and it's a very very
very effective version of that right
it's a very very indexable and effective
form of that and the thing that blows my
mind is you have people who are
otherwise seemingly intelligent that are
so basic [ __ ] with collecting their
notes you talk about guys that are into
your universe alright I'll be stuck in a
lecture and there's three four hundred
medics in there who are all supposedly
people they've been selected for their
academic aptitude and they're all sat
there with a flipping Microsoft Word
document for every new left you're like
open new
savers really upsets me it's just like
so if your student
like never know in Google Drive right
even everyone who I've told to do it
there was on you you never knew doing
and then they'll get it and they'll be
like oh my god I wish I'd go evidence
it's synced across if it's synced across
you phone your iPad your laptop it's all
things I thought you can put images in
it's holding this Evernote Web Clipper
as well so if you are other workers
photos and you're like oh I want to save
that articles press one key and it saves
it to your Evernote and it'll detect
based on the words in the note what
notebook it should go in based on the
context of the other notes or you can
change it quite easily that's one
feature over know that I don't use TF
it's fun to us I just never I don't ever
find myself in a position where I look
at something and think I read that way
except what I do is I a lot of time I
sign up for things that a member on the
access and then cancel within seven days
and snip them into your Evernote and
then I've got one more thing I'm sorry
go ahead scannable see yeah that's a
much better service and I'm just how
often have you been asked to like
provide proof of address or what's the
NHS number in fact today I've been asked
to proof of address Anna NHS number both
of which I've got within five seconds as
a junior doctor who's an Arab that
probably happens quite a lot whereas in
the past this you know to try and get
hold of though gonna hold you birth
certificate or something like that
you have to go through the special
drawer find the thing whereas if you
just have all of your admin documents in
one thing you can get your National
Insurance number or any of our stuff
just and you hold that in Evernote right
you can do like you know is that where
you hold it yeah
accountable will allow you to know blood
struggles fantastic I use Microsoft lens
which is the same thing but scannable by
Evernote yes it just puts a strange
revenue yeah yeah little bit more so I
when you say fist so I think the first
thing you mention is probably a lot of
the stuff you not have it's because of
you sir yeah absolutely
like we again we have trickled down
productivity tools yeah because what
you're saying there about like people
sit sign lectures on with Microsoft Word
all the difference between that I knew
is you just have a question in mind when
it comes to that thing you look at that
and think there's got to be a better way
to do that I'm gonna bloody I think I
was really intolerant like well I open a
Microsoft Word document and that 15
seconds of
is absolutely absolutely a fine dinner
and a good a good point dad the story
that I love about what you did before
you went to go and do you medical degree
was that you absolutely pounded that
like rushing oh god memory system or
whatever that way you've got a mind
Palace now that was a big undertaking
now one of one of the hardest courses do
60 seconds on that so if you go in mind
puppy
yes so the is a Russian memory system
that allows you to geometrically
increase the capacity for the problem is
it's not like are you retail improve
your memory it's a technique so it's not
like a what's learning how to bench it's
not getting a 300 kilo one rep much yes
exactly but there's a lot of tools in
there but it's just it's very laborious
and how many volumes was it was in
multiple vote yes I retreat 30 40
volumes or something like this isn't
gonna this isn't presented in like nice
polished Vimeo videos there's not any s
old Russian text dusty sell us some yeah
it's very very good stuff though it's so
okay I'm gonna run through you and the
listeners through this quick experiment
so I want you guys to between you think
of 10 objects so one to ten before you
do I'm going to give you a skeleton to
hook these onto bun shoot tree door hive
sticks heaven gate pine hen okay you can
remember those words because they are
rhyming with 1 to 10 yeah this is know
where it's at one bun two shoe 3 3 4
five 5 six 6 seven 7 eight 8 nine 9 ten
10 okay I've already forgotten yeah
remember that one door no bun I do it's
in free door okay I'll get three and
five so just just so they can it's just
so that I can explain what happened
we went extinct we went to David Lloyd
we needed to remember the code to get
out of the road in the bug is gone what
it was and he just shouted two words at
me
what was it it was 23 yeah and you just
shouted is it zero to three yeah and
they shouted tomorrow probably because
that's when you you convert the the
numbers to syllables which but anyways
you ever feel like you're around right
now no back on the number tomorrow with
a loud meeting with the human but that's
a different system that's a bit more
upfront learning investment just
explained as a as a concept there's
that's your framework okay and then a
bun there comes a lumpy what's the legs
number alone what's the reason for you
touching something visual to it because
memory works on resonance
whereas we think it works on just sheer
attrition or like repetition falls yeah
now even repetition or even stuff that
you think you learn an isolated fact is
always hooked on to some existing thing
within your structure of your brain so
the way that you have like an electrical
circuit or resonance so you have like a
guitar string and if you play a
frequency that's the same frequency as
that the guitar strings start to vibrate
as well so you need the existing thing
in your brain and then the trigger to go
and retrieve that okay so just a more
efficient way of finding yeah what's
that's it you're looking for now you
already have the numbers one to ten in
your mind you already have the ability
to rhyme in your mind
mm-hm so one and bun so that's
conceptual that's yeah that's conceptual
you can generate that at any time
whereas you you want the trigger to find
out what the object one was and so you
say okay one bun that's the hook that's
the retrieval system and then that will
resonate with the image that you've
created over vlaka with the lamp on and
then that comes back and clip it
completes the circuit okay so that's
okay so that's you have ten things you
want to remember ten things yeah that's
a framework you use yeah do you always
use burn for one I don't use that system
that's just like that's the base that's
the entry that's the entry level once
we've got you forth done degree black
you actually forget the numbers
altogether well location there's a good
way to do it so you remember you think
of a room that you know so you come into
the room you walk clockwise around the
room identify 20 objects have been in
the room the first object has identified
five pieces within the object so like
let's say it's a laptop you think like
the top bit the camera the screen the
keyboard the trackpad and the USB port
so those are the different objects you
then zoom in you attach another object
to each of them and you create a chain
for each part of the object so then one
object has the capacity for 125 bits of
information and so that's one object
within a room of 20 objects and so then
one room has 125 times 24 a lot capacity
for bits of data and then tell us about
the time that you entered the gym with
you balland oh so to bring everything
back John said yeah I had some of that
shorts that doesn't really have a proper
fly so it's very easy to just slip out
and so I walked into the big crowded
room in the gym for it I was in that for
a good 10 minutes now I realize that I'd
come out to play that's not really about
was not a life hack was it and just to
tell me I'm not I really go luckily
you're fine
yeah cuz because he would have had to
have notified it for podcast again
because you're both vulnerable adults
the inappropriately right John Europe
vortex hmm
so relate okay again related to
consuming media I see all the time and I
nearly did this for myself people
setting a goal which is like I'm gonna
read this many books this year or I'm
gonna do this listen this money whatever
like consume this amount of information
and I think something that I a question
that I have used to have which is
related to Esau was just saying it's
like read this book you take these notes
they're like what do you do with those
notes or what's the point of that
unless you're reading it in in some way
like unless the book is in and of itself
just a pleasure read like most people
read self-help books because they want
help with something to do with himself
so not having a way to apply that was
something that I struggle with a long
time so the way that I changed reading
is something right it's something that I
got from a guy called Garrett white
which I'll talk about in the next the
next round but it's simply just reading
to the point of having what he calls a
revelation which is just something and
you have this all the time when you read
or consume information of something that
for whatever reason make has an impact
on you resonates with you makes you that
like triggers a chain of thoughts you
raise it to that thing and then once
that happens once might take two minutes
might take 40 minutes stop reading go to
Evernote and I have notebooks for themes
so like fitness and training mindset
exactly yeah and in each of those
notebooks or in each of those notes is
just a series of pieces of information I
write down the thing that I heard in
bold and then just a few notes in my own
words beneath that and then I'll put if
there's something associated what they
usually as an action associated with it
like for example today it was change
some changed the about page on program
fitness calm lay it to a podcast it was
completely unrelated to marketing in any
way but the amount that goes in my
trailer so I added tomorrow reminders
which is synced with if this and that
through trailer and then I know that I
have a process in the morning when I
prioritize my day that i'll at some
point get through that I was still
talking about getting things out of my
head again there you know if the set is
the same thing but it's a way of making
sure that things that I put into my head
done so they stay stuck in there
absolutely the what was interesting did
you see the Tim Ferriss thing I think it
was what he did last week and he talks
about how he deals with information
overload and one of the things witness
says it uses this tagline
the good [ __ ] sticks mmm and it's like
you do consume a lot of information if
you in any way inclined to reading a lot
or chasing down the sort of self-help
rabbit hole so to speak is I guess we
are that you do end up becoming so
overwhelmed with information you can't
pull it back out and you worry well I've
read this book and it was a thousand
words a thousand pages long and I think
we're all glad what have I got out the
other side of this and Tim Ferriss is
piece of advice was if it's not if you
read all of those pages and nothing
comes out the other side of it then
don't worry and if you read one book and
you get ten concepts out of it then
that's fine because the good [ __ ] sticks
I think that's a really light interest I
really agree with them I think the only
part of it that I disagree with and this
might just be his ability or my
inability is this definitely notes that
I've made on previous books I look back
over and gone like oh yeah
and so what I try it what I'm trying to
do is just by the time I've finished a
book I've either already applied
everything that I've learned from that
book in some way or I have you know at
some point in the next couple months
they will be applied and far rather have
like one book a year
it's totally improved one part of my
life like relationships yeah
productivity what I've sleep whatever
then have ten books that I forgot about
tell me that's an important thing like
making this balance between acquisition
of information and application hmm and
some people are too far one way some
people too far the other way either too
far in the acquisition not in an
application some people read a book
every five years and so maybe they need
to obsess over yeah let's do let's do a
full round we'll do a final round for
this episode okay and we will do a full
round on the most basic one that you can
think of so my most basic one to get
started would be prepping your food
every day and it's something that not
everybody does but the benefits of
prepping your food are so ridiculously
large from an economic perspective from
a time perspective from a dietary
control perspective from a mood
perspective if you get up in the morning
and instead of eating your breakfast
whilst watching the TV the time
to eat your breakfast I promise you if
you have a coffee wait for the coffee to
cool and have a normal-sized breakfast
that doesn't take too much cooking you
will be able to wash up yesterday's
washing up cook your food for the day
and pack it by the time you've eaten
your breakfast and had your coffee takes
about for about half an hour to 40
minutes or so and by that time you've
done two things that you needed to do on
the morning but one of them will benefit
you for the entire rest of the day so
batch cook your food together make sure
that you've got chicken defrosted in the
morning or you've got your meat for the
day you've got some sort of carbs or
potatoes or whatever it might be and
then throw some vegetables in and you
can just boil everything away while
you're thinking about your day and your
cooking your food doing what I really
admire how consistent you are with us
it's just habit
it's just force of habit for me now and
it's been so drilled into me that when I
see people some of the guys will have to
leave the office at four o'clock in the
afternoon to go cook to go out to go to
go to a restaurant have food that's
sweet if you're eating out that's fine
we can also plan to eat out and yeah
maybe you're going to end up wasting
some food every so often because you've
cooked food and then you end up going
out for a meal but the price that you
play over the net the price that you pay
for for wasting the food that you may be
not going to be able to eat and you're
gonna have to throw away it's far lower
than the price you're gonna have to pay
by not cooking the food and then all you
have to eat out there your dietary
controls a lot less so yeah just in
whatever to whatever degree that you can
try and prep at least one meal a day
even if it's just your lunch let's say
that you that you're working a more
typical job daytime job you can eat your
breakfast on the morning you can prep
your lunch and come home to cook and eat
your tea it's to me it's just such a
no-brainer I know that you guys are on
and off with your food prep thing is
like that that's just our failing
because it's I'm completely sold on the
idea like it's a money saver time saver
and eliminates the possibility for you
to go off the rails with your diet
because the decisions made for you at
the start of the day like it's such a
like why how come how come how come you
don't tend to do it the reason I don't
do it knows because I I do the next best
thing which is ready meals plus like a
protein booster or a veg Buster or
whatever which works for me but like
I very much want to get back into it
like I do prep occasionally like every
third day but it's not as clockwork
because like I would do y'all put things
in a slow cooker put just chicken lemon
rosemary and sweet potato into it slow
cooker leave it for 12 hours it's tender
and ready to go yeah okay so have you
thought of a basic one yeah shoehorn
sure can you remember your facebook stay
that's right years ago so if you
consider the time that takes to put your
shoe on with the shoehorn and then
without a shoehorn so and the the amount
of skin that you lose on the back of
your thumb as well trying to thumb you
some of theirs and try these um it in
try to thumb there's a shoehorn help you
swim it in so much better really yeah
thank you thumb for it um so the way
that we is it amortize the the cost over
shoehorn is you you work out the amount
of time the number of times that you put
your shoes on every day four times a day
on average yep
number of tomber a mount of time that it
takes to put your shoe on without a
shoehorn
20 seconds total well let's say 20
milliseconds between two shoes or thinks
for a second between two shoes now the
saving will be about 17 seconds x 4 x
reads by a year at your hourly wage the
cost of the chute one pays for itself
the 69p that you pay for a shoehorn on
ebay will pay for itself very quickly so
I like it really like on day one it'll
pay for itself maybe the early is that
amortization yeah what's yours I want to
do two things but both you laugh oh
maybe both of them fantastic
I love saris is that this is for people
who work in an office okay picture was
you did I did I think so something I've
used to observe and I was the same a lot
of people would have liked coffee with
her breakfast in the morning and then
against about half 10 or 11 o'clock and
there's a bit of a like whip around to
go to the local cops
Nathu yeah like I was a coffee man
outside and his little van
or like a local Starbucks and people do
that every day for example and so what I
was started realizing was actually like
the coffee that you get is normally
unless it's like an iced coffee shop
artisan is normally pretty [ __ ] and like
two or three quid the coffee that I make
at home is normally pretty nice
I've bridesmaid blended - exactly how am
I like this how I like it cuz I've done
it yeah and I know what I like because
I'm me yeah one of the benefits of being
me so so what I did was buy two
thermoses that are identical aha
contigo which i think is Spanish for
with you you spell this cont I Gio
wasn't as complicated as I thought and
so I taught me telling people about it
like I would arrive at work bring two
services up my bag putting on a pillow
like put me quit but actually if you add
up a saving space of a month it's in
mint found I keep I run the numbers on
that on one of our articles and every
it's like if you get Starbucks coffee
and a biscotti every day of the week
Monday and Friday every day for ten
years
it works hard to like 14 grand and then
if you could interest us the thing is
have you heard the argument against that
okay which is like so people worry about
that and then trash their credit rating
and like if you flipped it have a really
good credit rating and managed the macro
aspect of your founders in coffee the 40
grands like it relevant in the context
of like buying a house mmm - a credit
rating right now anyway okay so we've
got so unless that's one of them
automate that part of your life just
have an iced coffee for much less money
yeah second thing is which is
technically two things within scale or a
Wi-Fi scale yep another example of
upfront cost and it's similar situation
the moment we get our clients to way up
when selves every day the number of
mornings you wake up
it's on the scale you're downstairs [ __ ]
like forgot her a coffee caramel number
scale syncs wirelessly with the cloud
phone
it's just logged and graphed and think
so this is a winnings winning I think
they're now owned by Nokia yeah there
you said got one for free that's just in
front of the theme of the wedding is
sweet for free this week you have as
well watch and there you go to watch off
maintains an active I suppose of watch
is an activity tracker so that's the
next thing which is a Fitbit or some
kind of fitness watch yep mine currently
wearing doesn't tell the time but just
it's just accumulating data and want me
just in case I need it
so sleep activity basically got me a
some watch that doesn't tell the time
it's yeah yeah and actually really later
so the watch that does this Fitness
watch made by Fitbit that doesn't tell
the time is actually the cheapest on the
bus one it's cream wear it in the shower
can you can you do you like to know what
you're doing in the show but it means
about heart rate so the time that I used
to it doesn't track re the time just
doesn't do anything the time that I used
to forget to put my Fitbit back on again
who's always in the shower in the
morning do you find that the number of
steps that you take is an important part
of your training as a powerlifter
yes the hmm is that because that's the
only cardio you
it's an easy way it's an easy way to
average out Tara I'm doing 8000 steps if
I do 12,000 tell you what's crazy
on the next episode the first one that I
will do will be something called sleep
cycle and the data that I got the other
side of that is insane and I have a look
at a graph that it shows as soon as I
break eight and a half thousand steps
for the day
I sleep increases by 10 percent or more
that's cool crazy thank you very much
for your time and we will be back
particularly with a new episode
[Music]
you